um sam we say a deal is close and and
until we get
we're being what's being told is 2 000
pages of text
we won't know exactly what is within it
but i suppose the question is
what does the british government do with
this deal if indeed it is done
how do they get it out there to the
public how do they describe it
how do they trumpet their success so to
speak well
neil we've been waiting 1 645 days
to find out what brexit looks like in
practice so what does a few
more hours look like between friends uh
it does look
as if today a trade deal will be done
between the uk and the eu
which will sort out our future
relationship
uh with the block after we leave the
transition on january the
december the 31st it will cover a huge
amount of stuff from trade to security
to data to
essentially all aspects of how we
interact with the european union after
our
uh exit um we are expecting the
negotiations to wrap up maybe in the
next couple of hours but when has there
been a brexit deadline that we haven't
uh crashed through at which point we
will see
uh prime minister boris johnson probably
in a press conference
maybe as early as mid-morning at some
point
after that we should get this 2000 page
deal that you uh
that you refer to it's not exactly clear
the timing of that i think that one of
the objectives of the british government
will be to get out their side their
story about what it'll look like
first there'll be a story to tell about
sovereignty a story to tell
about how we've reclaimed our fishing
waters how there aren't uh any
terrorists but the detail really uh will
uh
hinge on what that intensely negotiated
document says
and for that i think we're gonna have to
wait several more hours